Putin has a problem
in fact he has a whole bunch of problems
uh problem one is uh what looked like a
brilliant psychological warfare
operation the meddling in the U.S
election has backfired massively on him
so that relations between the US and
Russia are at an all-time post-cold War
low Lindsey Graham remarked that it took
some Real Genius to unite Republicans
and Democrats in Congress and they were
United over tightening sanctions on
Russia problem two is you know Russia's
just not big enough to build its own
competitive Network structure it does
have them but they don't have the kind
of critical mass that that China has so
he's right to identify that he who
controls the networks will control the
21st century it won't be him the the
Russian networks basically uh outside of
Russia subsist for nefarious activities
so if you get booted off the uh the West
Coast the Silicon Valley networks then
you end up going to the Russian networks
to do whatever skullduggery you have in
mind and so the dark web is is partly a
Russian Russian Venture but here's the
trouble
in the uh in the world of of cyber
warfare
which is an extraordinarily important
part of our story that we haven't
touched on the ongoing constant conflict
on the internet between states and
non-state actors and companies in that
world of cyber warfare up until now the
Russians have essentially behaved like
poachers they have been to put it
crudely outside the tent
running with the bad boys the problem
about that is that Russia really is as
likely to be hit by cyber warfare as any
major State and it was uh to my mind uh
deeply satisfying to read that the one a
crime malware had infected more
computers in Russia than any other
country and I think at some point Russia
is going to have to recognize that it
cannot simply be the Renegade of the
great Powers running around with the Bad
actors on the internet it has to
recognize it's come common interest in
having some kind of order in cyberspace
and not what we have at the moment which
is a kind of Anarchy or permanent state
of War just to say Neil the wannacry was
an attack Cyber attack earlier this year
against software of bureaucracies of
many countries including this one
thought to originated in Russia uh well
it's probably not actually it was
actually a morphed U.S uh piece of
software we think which essentially
infected people who hadn't updated their
operating systems and locked them out of
their of their hard drives and the
Russians uh who if you go to Russia
don't necessarily always have the best
of software it's a little bit like the
NHS only it's a country
were affected almost as much as the NHS
and also most of its most effective
employees are foreigners
I said they have a lot in common I can
say this kind of thing because my father
worked all his life for the national
service National Health Service and
often drew a parallel uh between it and
the Soviet Union
at least it didn't have nuclear weapons
um
so networks as fickle this is a really
important Point uh the nightmare if
you're Mark Zuckerberg is in the
following data in the demographic under
30 more and more uh young people in the
United States are using SnapChat in
preference to Facebook and that must
worry him almost more than the Russia
inquiry and all the attendance Scandal
because if there were large-scale
defection by Young users then Facebook's
future would start looking a lot less
bright so yeah the system is ethical but
the following is true in all of these
different networked markets Winner Takes
all
a Winner Takes nearly all Eric Schmidt
puts this um the chairman of alphabet
the parent company of Google in the
following way it Zip's law z-i-p-f Zip's
law and in Zips law the winner gets 90
percent
some people get nine percent and the
rest get point nine percent
uh and so at the moment Facebook's the
winner take all just as Uber seemed to
be the winner take all uh in the ride
sharing contest but that can change my
space looked like it would win social
networking Myspace was invented before
Facebook but it's lunch got eaten so
yeah it's it's a Fickle volatile world
and one argument that is often made by
these big Network companies when they
are accused of being monopolies is
competition is just a click away and
that's become the standard defense
against the Anti-Trust uh suits that
some people talk about bringing against
these companies finally I'm very glad
you asked about the Revolutions of 1989
I was in uh Germany in 1989
and
you have to remember two things
one
all networks by definition start small
Facebook was just a bunch of Harvard
students initially
the key thing is not the starting size
it's the rate of growth
and the rates of growth of the crowds
and Leipzig was exponential I know this
because I did did the numbers uh for a
book I wrote uh I think it was
civilization uh I even have friends who
were there and in Leipzig a good
journalist friend of mine was there and
he said the scary thing at the beginning
of the Leipzig protests he was an early
member of the network was that the East
German uh security forces were there
with weapons and they were deeply afraid
that the uh the East German regime
hanukkah's regime would give the order
and there would be Tiananmen Square in
Leipzig but because it grew very rapidly
exponentially uh in those few months uh
there came a point when that was no
longer a viable option especially for a
regime that had essentially been told
not to do it by Gorbachev I revisit the
story of 1989 in this book
1989 was in some ways the best year of
my life I look back on it and I still I
still Marvel
that I was there and witnessed the
disintegration of the Berlin wall that
that year I wasn't there on the night
that it actually came down
I was there during the summer I even
wrote a piece with the title the Berlin
Wall is crumbling because I was
observing so many people crossing over
into West Berlin from other East
European countries where the travel
restrictions had been loosened like
Poland but the the newspaper that I sent
it to refused to publish it and the
editor this was communicated to me by
the deputy editor he said well Neil the
editor feels you've been listening to
too many Ronald Reagan speeches so my
piece my prophetic piece was never
published and is lost to posterity
because it was only on a little Tandy
which is the memory the size of a Nats
memory
in this book I look at the way that
networks of descent formed in the
country that was much more important
than East Germany namely Poland and
there's some terrific work on this by a
Polish scholar who's graphed all and
reconstructed all the different networks
the preceded solidarity
and shown how it was that solidarity for
a brief but crucial period was able to
join together all the different
dissident forces which range from the
right devout Catholic nationalists to
the left liberal leaning academics and
intellectuals so that illustrates the
point well Poland got critical mass of
dissident networks first and it was
there that that communist rule first
folded
thank you Neil and we've got another
round of questions now and I see hands
and numbers coming up there uh two okay
let's let's not necessarily do them in
order we've got a four over there I want
to make sure different parts of the hall
get taken up so four
let's take that one first and then make
sure we go around hi thanks very much
um so I wonder how you think that we can
utilize this understanding of network
specifically the Silicon Valley kind of
network to combat rather than encourage
Islamic terrorism
okay that's a very good question thank
you for that uh let's see is there a
number that yes we have a number three
on this side let's get number three
go ahead how do you think about the
relationship between hierarchy and
Regulation and what do you think is the
most appropriate way to regulate
Networks
very good question thanks for that and
let's there's another four but it's way
of the other side now so that's good
let's get that four hi you spoke earlier
about the hierarchy and the network I
was wondering if you had an opinion on
how the network seems to
almost need a hierarchy so if we look at
for example uh Wikipedia and how
originally it had no editors before
becoming uh an organization with editors
and almost peer driven or Facebook which
now has groups and group admins and
various other levels of hierarchy within
its tools
so last two questions both very good
questions almost related to each other
and then the question of course about
Islamic terrorism
well let me start with the question on
on Islamic terrorism and not only
terrorism but the the non-violent
Islamic extremism which I think is the
precursor of of violent action uh my
wife Ayan Hersey Ali has written an
important analysis of this showing how
dawa prizolitization is the Prelude to
Jihad
at the moment we're doing a pretty
terrible job
of this in two respects
one the networks have not been very
effective at preventing their use by
groups like uh Islamic State
and Islamic State I described this in
the book in fact I show a network graph
of Islamic States uh blogging presence
in 2013 prior to the the high profile
executions that suddenly got everybody's
attention the following year and it's
clear that Islamic State continues to be
able to function even on major platforms
by playing whack-a-mole with uh the
companies you close down one account and
another one opens and there isn't in
fact a good way of dealing
algorithmically with the way these
people operate and this relates to the
second and third questions I'm going to
talk about were still
what has happened in the last year or so
has been that those who speak out
against Islamic extremism are attacked
online relentlessly and viciously and
accused constantly of islamophobia and
this brings me to the questions of
hierarchy and Regulation and whether or
not
networks need a hierarchy and indeed
regulation the answer is they clearly do
they clearly do
the problem is how exactly do we
regulate
platforms with two billion users
generating vast quantities of content
that are clearly Beyond any human
editorial control
at the moment
we have seemed to have reached a
consensus in the United States
that these platforms are not Publishers
they are network platforms and they
continue to be regulated differently
from Publishers of content under the
1996 Communications decency act this
exemption means that people at Facebook
or for that matter at Google are not
responsible for what appears on their
platforms there's no liability there's
no responsibility to warm this exemption
puts them at a great Advantage relative
to Conventional Publishers who have
those liabilities under the law this is
an anomaly it must I think ultimately
change if it doesn't change we are going
to arrive in a situation at which
publication is essentially monopolized
or near-monopolized by the Silicon
Valley companies
who will claim to have no responsibility
for what is published and then when we
scream and shout as the European
commission does and says but you're
publishing terrible things they will
scramble higher fact Checkers and
editors and put up a show of trying to
suppress whatever they're told is hate
speech this is a completely dangerous
path to go down by the way because I
think the European commission is giving
even more power to these platforms by
telling them effectively to be sensors
on our behalf that seems to be the
German government's line I find it
extraordinary
but I think we ultimately need to
recognize that we haven't solved this
problem we're nowhere close to solving
it and I think that this will be one of
the major challenges not only in the
United States but in Europe indeed
everywhere in the Free World
how do we regulate such vast networks
that have never existed on this scale
before if we don't regulate them they
clearly have
power beyond the imaginings of the most
powerful press Baron as well as all the
advertising Revenue in the world
the two companies Google and Facebook
got 90 percent of all new online
advertising in the fourth quarter of
2016. if you're not in that business if
you're in the conventional publishing
business you are dying at this point so
we haven't figured this out and that's
partly what motivated me to write this
book this is a huge problem
and we don't know what to do Democrats
say let's break them up they're
monopolies let's do Anti-Trust like
progressives used to do
and that doesn't get very far because
they're natural monopolies how do you
break up Google
it's not conceivable that you could have
a sort of vulcanized search engine
Google Arkansas
it's not going to happen
it's not going to happen then I think
there's some very hard thinking to be
done about what regulation these should
be given they are
utilities the Supreme Court Rana
recently said they are the Public Square
which was good for me since I had called
my book already the square and the tar
this is the Public Square but who owns
it